- Hi everyone, welcome to
the Homeroom livestream,
Sal here from Khan Academy.
A happy National Constitution
Day for all of you all
from the United States.
And we'll be digging deep
into the U.S Constitution
with one of the world's
leading experts on it.
So, let's start putting your questions in
on Facebook and YouTube,
and we will be able to
surface these questions.
But before we jump into our conversation,
I'll give my standard
announcement reminder
that Khan Academy is a
not-for-profit organization.
We can only exist
through philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please go to khanacademy.org/donate.
Also wanna give a special
thanks to several organizations
that stepped up when they realized that
we were running at a deficit
even before the COVID crisis hit.
And when COVID hit,
we had to accelerate a whole
series of our programs.
Our server costs went up,
because our traffic went up dramatically.
Our registrations went up,
so special thanks to Bank of America,
Google.org, AT&T, fastly and Novartis.
But I will remind everyone we are still
running at a deficit,
especially for next year.
So any support you could
provide is very, very valuable.
So with that, I'm excited
to introduce Jeff Rosen,
who I've known for many years
cause we've collaborated on
some things at Khan Academy.
Jeff, good to see you happy National,
was it Constitution Day?
- Happy Constitution Day Sal, absolutely.
And it's great to see you too.
So glad I'm here.
- So maybe a couple of quick questions.
Why is today National
Constitution Day, September 17th?
- So September 17th, 1787
was the day the Constitution was signed
in Independence Hall in Philadelphia.
It wasn't made a national
holiday, until 2004.
There've been precursors of it,
in 1940, there was something
called Citizenship Day,
but basically ever since a law in 2004,
sponsored by Senator Robert Byrd,
the U.S has recognized the anniversary
of the day when the
Constitution was signed.
- Makes a lot of sense.
And for those not familiar,
what does the National
Constitution Center do?
Which you lead.
- The National Constitution Center,
like your phenomenal work Sal,
is a non-profit that teaches
people about the Constitution.
And we have this amazing online resource
called The Interactive
Constitution that contains videos,
Sal, we've done together with you
and with people like Justice
Neil Gorsuch and Elena Kagan.
It has early drafts of every
provision of the Constitution.
It has essays by leading liberal
and conservative scholars
describing what they agree
and disagree about the Constitution.
And most excitingly, recently,
we're offering live
classes on the Constitution
that you can find that on
the interactive Constitution
or at constitutioncenter.org.
Three days a week my colleagues and I
just turn on the computer and are offering
classes for middle, high
school and college kids
about Constitution 101.
Everything from the beginning
through the bill of rights.
It's so meaningful as you know Sal
cause you've been such
a pioneer to be able
to use this COVID crisis as an opportunity
to offer free online education.
And friends, if you're
watching at home I hope you'll
join us for these classes.
We just did one today at
noon for Constitution Day.
A live class with Justice Gorsuch.
Who's the honorary chair
of the National Constitution Center.
And we had a 4,500 students of all ages,
middle school are up,
asking Justice Gorsuch, amazing questions.
So that's what the
Constitution center does.
In addition to all that,
we're a beautiful museum
of the Constitution
on Independence Mall in Philadelphia.
We are now opened again,
so if you happen to be in Philadelphia,
come see the very earliest
drafts of the Constitution,
as well as the re-construction Amendments,
the 19th Amendment, which
gave women the right to vote
and be inspired by the thrill of learning
about U.S Constitution.
- And this might be an obvious question,
but I think it's worth asking.
So the Constitution actually,
this wasn't obvious to me
when I first learned it,
you know, you just learned
the word Constitution.
And then like, literally I was in my 30's
one day when I woke up in
the morning I was like,
Oh, because it constitutes the country.
It like says what the country is made of.
How does it run, et cetera, et cetera.
I never made that connection
like my entire life
until I was like 38 years old.
But why is it important?
Obviously it's important
to have a Constitution.
But why is it important
to keep reflecting on it
and studying it, you know,
to have students be able to
talk to Supreme Court Justices,
to have a museum around this?
Why is that important to keep
reflecting on the Constitution?
- You know, you're so right
to emphasize that word
constitute because a Constitution
is what constitutes us
as a people, as we the people.
And those words of the preamble,
we the people of the United States
were hugely significant
of the framer James Wilson
insisted that the preamble begin with
we the people of United
States not his original draft.
We the people of the
States of Rhode Island
and Virginia and so forth
because we believe that
we the national people
have the sovereign power.
It wasn't like England
where the King had the power
or where parliament have the power.
It was we the people as
a whole who had the power
and we all know friends that
these are such divided times.
According to some scholars
were more polarized
than at any time since the civil war.
The text of the Constitution
is the one thing
that continues to bind and constitute us.
And it doesn't mean that we agree about
what it means always,
but we can agree and disagree respectfully
on the basis of our Constitutional
not our political views.
And in that sense,
studying the Constitution
and the various arguments on all sides
of Constitutional questions,
helps us to have the civil dialogue
that the framers thought was necessary,
if we are continued to be
constituted as we the people.
- And even what you just
pointed out about how,
you know, early revisions had
we the people of the States of
versus obviously the Constitution we have,
which is we the people
of the United States,
you know, we take even words
like United for granted.
That's just the name of
our country, United States.
But that was a really important point
because you could have
constituted as essentially of
confederation of Quasi-independent
states or nations
or however you wanna talk about it.
And that's obviously what the articles
of confederation world we're all about.
But then they said, well
that's too federated.
We're gonna be one people.
- That's exactly right.
And as you say, Sal was that
defects of the articles of confederation
that led those guys to come
to Philadelphia in 1787.
The Articles of Confederation
viewed each state as sovereign.
And in order to do anything
you had to have unanimous consent.
So it was impossible to
pay off the war debts,
to have foreign policy,
individual states for raising
tariffs against each other.
So the framers come to Philadelphia
with this very difficult task.
They have to create a central
government, strong enough
to protect common purposes,
but constrained enough to protect liberty.
And it could have gone lots of ways.
The very,
it's so cool, if you go on
The Interactive Constitution,
you can see the early
drafts of The Preamble
and the very first words
that Wilson chose weren't,
we the people, it was just resolve
the government of the United States
shall consist of a legislative, judicial
and executive branch.
That was it.
Those three branches of
government were the big idea.
But note, then after
further debate it was clear.
The branches don't have
the sovereign power.
None of them can speak for us.
We the people are sovereign.
But then, the next profound question,
which people are sovereign?
Is it the people of the individual states
or the sovereign states?
Now in insisting that the
United States were sovereign
and that the style of the United States,
according to the second graph
shall be the United States of America.
Wilson was introducing a radical idea,
James Wilson or rather Abraham Lincoln.
When the south tried to
succeed from the union
during the civil war,
invoked James Wilson's idea of
national popular sovereignty
and said, you can't do
that, Southern States.
We the people of the
United States as a whole
having made the union,
we need the consent of the
entire people to change it.
And it took the civil war
to settle that question.
So look at how much we've reflected on.
And we haven't even gotten past
the first three words of the Constitution.
Just by digging into the text,
the history, the case law,
we can learn so much
about the evolving notion
of who we are as a people.
- That was very powerful.
And actually another thing
which you touched on,
but, you know, these are
these things that I had
like these epiphanies in
my 30s and I was like,
Oh, of course, you know,
in the United States,
we call each state a state because
they were initially
envisioned to be like a state.
Like a Quasi-independent state.
In most countries you
call these provinces.
You don't call them states.
But we've kept that even though
we really are a part of one country.
Quick question is really
kind of a technical question,
which I think I know the answer,
but I'll let you answer it from YouTube,
Smart Bear is asking Jeff,
what are the prices to enter the classes?
I'm assuming the ones with
the Supreme Court justices,
Can you attend the classes worldwide?
What did the classes talk about?
- So glad you asked
and thrilled to share that
they're completely free.
You can sign up on Zoom
and that allow you
to chat questions just
as you're doing now.
But we also stream them on YouTube
and all the archive videos
are available on our YouTube site
and on the interactive Constitution,
which you can find at
constitutioncenter.org.
What do the classes talk about,
we have a complete schedule
from the fall through the Spring
week by week and you can find those,
our remote learning resource page.
And just this week we talked about
the Constitutional convention
and my colleague Karry Satner
wheeled her Zoom camera
around Signers' Hall.
And we went up to individual
statues in particular framers
and talked about their ideas
and how they influence the convention.
We're gonna be talking about
the electoral college about
separation of powers, we'll do deep dives
into each of the major Amendments,
the all four clauses
of the first Amendment,
the second Amendment, the fourth Amendment
detecting unreasonable
searches and seizures.
We'll talk about re-construction
and slavery in the Constitution.
It's just such a thrill,
we just have this kind of crazy idea that
everyone from middle
school to high school,
all the way up is engaged enough to learn
the kind of substantive
Constitutional law that
Justice Gorsuch in the Supreme
Court interprets every day.
And it's really exciting to see
everyone from middle school students
and we do different middle
school and high school classes,
jumping right in, reading
Supreme Court opinions,
debating the ideas.
It's very inspiring to see
how citizens are able to
rise to the challenge.
So I would love it if everyone
who's here would just
check out the schedule,
watch them live, watch the
archive videos on YouTube.
Tell me what you think.
jeffrosen@constitutioncenter.org
and learn about the Constitution together.
It's such a great privilege we have.
- Now I'm excited about,
frankly I wanna learn more,
but also for my family
to engage with that.
I think that's incredible.
You know, going into
the Constitution itself.
And obviously people could,
I actually highly recommend people
to look at the text of the Constitution.
I think most people watching
are fully capable of reading it.
You don't have to be a lawyer.
You don't have to be a historian.
It is quite approachable.
But you know, one of the things
that all has always fascinated me
is this notion of Amendments,
you know, and we have the bill of rights
for first 10 Amendments.
The original authors of the Constitution,
how much did they think
it was going to be an evolving document?
I mean, I guess they started
off kind of out the gate,
evolving it a little bit
with the bill of rights.
So and do you think they
would have been surprised
that we haven't amended it more?
Or they would have been surprised
by how much we have amended it?
- Such a great question.
I mean, we can tell something about that
from the debate over whether
to have a bill of rights
in the first place.
So James Madison, who's the
main author of the Constitution
originally opposes a bill of rights
cause he thinks it's
unnecessary or dangerous.
It's unnecessary he says,
cause the Constitution
itself is a bill of rights,
since it only grants
Congress limited powers,
therefore Congress can't claim it
as the power to abridge
free speech, for example,
because it's not granted that power.
And then he says it's dangerous
to have a bill of rights because
if you have a list of rights,
people might wrongly think that
if a right isn't written
down, it's not protected.
And he thought channeling The
Declaration of Independence,
that our rights come from God
or nature not from government.
And therefore you can't make a close list.
There are so many of them
you couldn't even begin
to write them all down,
but then the anti-federalists
persuaded him to change his mind.
They basically said
better safe than sorry.
All of the state Constitutions
have bills of rights
since everyone knows
what the rights are let's
write down the main ones which they did,
adding the ninth Amendment which said
the enumeration of certain rights
shall not be construed
to deny or disparage
others retained by the people.
That's a reminder that don't assume
if it's not written
down it's not protected.
You know, as to the question of
did they expect it to change more?
Will the be surprised that
there there've been only 27 Amendments?
There was definitely a
variation of views on this.
Jefferson who was not at the
Constitutional convention.
He was in Paris at the time
thought there should be essentially
a new convention every generation.
And you had to allow each
generation to go back
to first principles and
draft a new Constitution
and it would be great to have
lots of Amendments or even
to start from scratch.
Madison completely disagreed.
He was at the convention.
He thought it was basically a miracle
that this group of fallible
human beings were able to come to
the agreement that they did.
And it would be really
dangerous to roll the Dyson,
open things up to another convention.
So he was much more reluctant
to have more Amendments.
And he wanted us always to
be guided by what he called
reason rather than passion.
He wanted a very slow
and deliberate process
for Constitutional change.
And perhaps he would not be dissatisfied.
There have been relatively few Amendments.
So that was some of the debate.
But, it's remarkable, isn't it?
That there have been only 27 Amendments
in all of American history.
Those first 10 are the bill of rights.
And each of them is worth studying.
One final thing I'll say
is this evening at 6:30 PM,
live free on constitutioncenter.org.
We are giving our Liberty Medal,
the 2020 Liberty medal to
Justice Ruth Baden Ginsburg.
And it's an incredibly inspiring series
of video tributes from
her favorite Opera singers
and special friends talking about
all that she's done for the Constitution.
And she has a very memorable vision.
She says the Constitution has
become ever more embracive.
And when I asked her once
what she meant by that word,
she's meant embracing the left out people,
not just grudgingly but with open arms.
So in Justice Ginsburg's vision,
the Constitution was
intended by its framers
to be increasingly embracive.
So the promise of The
Declaration of Independence
that all men are created
equal could be extended
to all men and women to people
of all races, creeds, colors,
to immigrants, to LGBTQ people.
She believes that that
more embracive Constitution
was envisioned by the framers.
Now, others disagree.
People who are considered themselves
Constitutional originalists
believe that the Constitution
is only supposed to evolve
through the Amendment process
and any efforts to expand its protections
through judicial interpretation
are a violation of the
original understanding
of the Constitution.
So that debate broadly
between call them originalists
or strict constructionist
and living Constitutionalists
is very much alive on
the Supreme Court today.
And it's great just to study
the different methodologies
of Constitutional interpretation.
So you friends who were watching
can make up your own mind
about who you agree with.
Are you a originalist?
Are you in a living Constitutionalist?
Would you mix and match
different methodologies like
pragmatism or representation,
reinforcement or textualism?
We can kind of walk out by
thinking like a justice
and talking about those
different approaches,
but it's always really inspiring
to try to approach these questions,
not in political but in
Constitutional terms.
In other words, don't ask what
do you think the government
should do in a particular case,
but what do you think
the Constitution allows
or forbids it to do
and be guided in your
answer to that question
by being faithful to your methodology.
So if you're a originalist in one case,
you should be that in another case,
even if it leads to a
result you don't like
and vice versa for living competition.
So that's some of our
evangelism is to excite
all of you students who are watching
to think like a Constitutional lawyer,
learn those methodologies
and make up your own mind.
- That was fascinating.
What would you say?
You know, it does feel like
earlier on in our history,
we had more frequent Amendments
and for very good reason
we had some major issues
in our early phases of our
country around slavery,
around women not having the right to vote.
And obviously even though
the Constitution got amended,
some of many of the inequities,
many of the problems
have continued and to some degree
some of them are still there.
What do you think?
And to some degree maybe
this more interpreted version
versus an originalist
version of the Constitution
maybe makes the Amendment process
a little bit less of a
must have is one theory,
but I'm curious, you know,
well we have a question actually
from India Hussein Akir says,
it's a lawyer from India
enlighten us regarding
the procedure of Amendment
of the Constitution of the U.S
and the reason why I'd love
you to answer that question
is because my perception
it's a very hard thing to do
and my second or third
part of this question
is what do you think is in
the running for Amendment?
I mean, you know, we think, we
hear a lot of people talking
about the electoral college
or is, you know, every
state getting a senator
only two senators,
California has two senators
while the next 40 million people have,
you know, 40 senators or whatever.
What do you think is in the running
and maybe our lifetimes that might,
where we might see an Amendment.
- Great question from India,
India has such a distinguished
Constitutional condition
And your Supreme Court is
really one of the great
and really influential
and important Supreme
Courts around the world.
So how do you amend the U.S Constitution?
Well, there are a bunch of ways to do it,
according to article
five of the Constitution,
which sets out the Amendment process.
First, the Amendment has to be proposed.
There are two ways it can be proposed.
It can either be proposed by two thirds
of both Houses of Congress
or by a special Constitutional convention
called by congress
on the application of
two thirds of the states.
Most of the Amendments that
have been proposed have used
the first method of proposal by Congress.
We haven't had another
Constitutional convention
since the first one.
And then it can be ratified
in two ways as well.
It can be either ratified
by three quarters
of the State Legislatures
or by special conventions
called in three quarters of the States.
So that's why the Constitution
is so hard to amend
because you got to jump
through all of those hoops
and three quarters is a really high bar.
What Amendments are most likely?
The one that's very much on the table
is the Equal Rights Amendment.
Just last year Virginia ratified
the Equal Rights Amendment
year after its proposal in
the 1980s or early 1980s.
And some claim that because
Virginia represents basically,
puts us over the three quarters hump,
the ERA should be part
of the Constitution.
But others disagree
because the original ERA
had a time limit and said
that it had to be ratified
by the 1980s and the
time limit has passed.
And therefore, in addition
to the fact that some States
have rescinded their ratification,
people say it is not valid.
Justice Ginsburg, who is
one of the most influential
advocates of Equal Rights Amendment
thinks it would be safer
to start from scratch.
Which if there's enough doubt
about the validity of the ERA,
It'd be better to re-propose
it and re ratify it
because you wanna be sure that it's
definitely part of the Constitution.
And then in terms of what
other Amendments are likely,
surprisingly the Amendment that
has been proposed most often
and ratified by most States is,
I wanna ask you to guess,
because it wasn't intuitive to me
but it's The Balanced Budget Amendment,
which has gotten nearly
two thirds of the States.
I think it's like three
or four States short
of the three quarters benchmark.
So that's probably the first
one likely to be ratified
if that were actually to happen.
Then there's also been
a term limits Amendment
that's not nearly as
close to being ratified.
And those two are at the top of the list.
- So just to make sure I understand.
So The Balance Budget Amendment,
I actually was not aware of this.
I mean, they should be like
tracking this in the news
that would force a balanced budget
on the federal government?
- Exactly, right.
- So that would be a huge thing
because then all of a sudden
Fiscal policy is a tool
becomes significantly stopped,
(Chuckling)
I guess, especially when running deficit.
- Imagine in the time of
COVID given the deficits
we're running, all of that
with the unconstitutional
if we had a balanced budget Amendments
so we have a huge time period.
- Fascinating, once the state ratifies it,
can they undo their ratification
or they have to vote again
to undo the ratification.
- They have to vote again and it's obvious
really interesting legal questions about
whether you're allowed to or not.
Several States did undo or
resend their ratifications
of ERA and there's a
debate among lawyers about
whether those decisions are valid or not.
In the end it's sort of up to,
well, the last contestant Amendment we had
was the 27th Amendment.
Was originally proposed as
the original second Amendment
back at the time of the bill of rights
and it says that Congress
can't raise its salary
without an intervening election.
It had got a bunch of States to ratify it
and then people forgot about it.
And then in the 1990s, I
think, a college student said,
hey, we're two States
short of ratification or so
just a few more ratifications
since there's no time limit here
would make this part of the Constitution.
He got a failing grade on the paper
cause his teacher thought
it was so outlandish,
but a bunch of States
took up a suggestion,
ratified the Amendment
and the arc of this,
the United States decided on his own
that it was part of the Constitution
after the final ratification came through
and certified it.
And it was then inscribed
in the Constitution
as the 27th Amendment.
And the story Justice Gorsuch
told this the noon today.
He thinks that the guy
had his grade reversed
after the Amendment was ratified.
But it's a great example of how,
when there's no time
limit on an Amendment,
it's kind of up to well in
that case, just the archivist
and then people's willingness to accept it
about whether or not it's valid
in the question of precision
is equally interesting.
- That's incredible, that's a facet.
When did this happen?
(indistinct)
- Well, I think it became,
I can pull out the
interactive Constitution.
You guys will figure it out,
but it was in the early 1990s
when the 27th Equal Rights Amendments was.
- Wow! And the Equal Rights Amendments,
you know, I've watched the,
I forgot the name of the Netflix show,
I watched it with my wife
a couple of months ago
about the attempt to pass
The Equal Rights Amendment
in the seventies and early eighties,
which was about the whole
women's rights movement
and all of that with those
was all intertwined with that.
I highly recommend it.
I wouldn't recommend it
for like really young kids.
It gets a little bit adult
in some of their things,
but what would be the implications
if The Equal Rights
Amendment gets fully adopted.
- That's a really interesting question.
And here I'll just plug
the weekly podcasts
we do at the Constitution
Center called "We The People"
where every week I call
up a leading liberal
and conservative scholar and
debate questions like the one
Sal just ask,
and we did have a podcast on the ERA
and what it would mean a few months ago.
And as usual, it's complicated,
people disagree about what it would mean.
But the progressive scholar thought
it would be a strong basis
for reproductive rights.
Justice Ginsburg has
argued that restrictions
on a woman's right to choose violate
not the right to privacy of male doctors
but the right of equality of women
whose life choices are constrained
by not being able to choose to be,
caregivers or not based on
their own individual choice.
So it might be used to argue
for a right of reproduction
and to argue to strike down
restrictions on that way.
Others say that it would
require, for example,
LGBTQ people to have transgender bathrooms
and would forbid bathrooms
that are marked for people
who identify as male or female.
Others disagree about that.
Others say that it would
allow courts to root out
unconscious gender bias
as a form of a violation
of discrimination on the basis of sex
rather than intentional discrimination.
Which so far the Supreme Court
has held is the only kind of
discrimination that's forbidden.
Now, you can argue all of this
round or flat as the lawyer say,
and you could say that since
the Constitution already
guarantees equal protection of the law,
and since the Supreme Court just last term
in a six to three decision
by justice Gorsuch
held the title seven of the
Civil Rights Act of 1964.
And it's forbidding
discrimination on the basis of sex
covers not only gender discrimination,
but also discrimination on
the basis of LGBTQ status,
that an ERA wouldn't add all that much
to that existing statutory protection.
The final thing I'll say
when you ask a great
Constitutional question
there's always a technical
answer that you can't know
unless you've heard the
arguments on both sides.
And I didn't know this until the podcasts.
Justice Ginsburg when she was an advocate
arguing before the Supreme Court
said that discrimination
on the basis of sex
should be treated just a
skeptically under the law
as discrimination on the basis of race.
And the lawyers test for that
is called strict scrutiny.
And it means that any burdens on the right
have to be necessary to achieve
a compelling governmental interest.
The Supreme Court never quite adopted
Justice Ginsburg standard
and in the Virginia
Military Institute case
which she wrote,
which struck down separately
equal military academies
for men and women.
The court adopts said
that gender discrimination
should be treated nearly as skeptically,
as discrimination on the basis of race.
We needed an exceedingly
persuasive justification
and ERA would unequivocally guarantee
strict scrutiny and require
a compelling interest
for gender discrimination.
And in that sense,
it would certainly put
discrimination on the basis of sex
on the same legal plan,
there's discrimination
on the basis of rights.
- Well, that's fascinating.
And I mean, it's also fun to see how
passionate you look like.
You know, you're like an
artist when you get into this,
you know, just to get,
make sure we're not
leaving everyone behind it.
I do have two questions from YouTube.
Smart Bear is asking what is an Amendment?
And Nish 76 is what is
meant by Amendments?
I feel so lost.
So that's another thing Amendment
literally means to amend,
to add, to modify,
anything you would add to,
anything you would amend to
my explanation of Amendments.
- I just would add synonyms change, alter,
put in, add.
I think that was one of your words,
change, alter, add is
what an Amendment is.
So the original Constitution,
remember we said, didn't
have a bill of rights.
So the first 10 changes
to the Constitution
are called Amendments.
The first Amendment says,
Congress shall make no law
abridging the freedom of
speech or of the press.
And you had to amend or
change the Constitution
to guarantee that right of free speech.
Cause it didn't appear in
the original Constitution.
So an Amendment is the
change to the Constitution,
but it's so it's actually
quite a deep question.
Of course, as all of
your great questions are
because in changing the Constitution,
you're incorporating a principle into it
that has just as much weight
as the original principles.
So in some cases you have to
read the original Constitution
in light of its subsequent Amendments.
And to give the most important example,
the original Constitution
only bound Congress.
It didn't bound the states.
It says Congress shall make no law,
abridging free speech it didn't say
the state shall make no law.
The 14th Amendment to the Constitution
was intended to apply all
of those original Amendments
against the states as well as congress
through the privileges
or immunities clauses,
it's called the Doctrine of Incorporation
and the bottom line friends again,
I know it's getting technical again,
but it's usually important.
Just think of this.
After the 14th Amendment
passed after the civil war,
the states are just as prohibited from
infringing free speeches congress was
before the 14th Amendment they were free
to infringe free speech
in Federal Constitution.
So that's what an Amendment is.
And any time you wanna
change the Constitution,
at least changes the text,
you have to pass an Amendment.
- Yeah, it's, you're definitely adding
to the text of the Constitution,
I guess you could, or to the overall text,
I guess you could say,
cause you're adding more
and it could be a change to your point
with the 14th Amendment or
it could be clarification,
you know, the first
Amendment doesn't contradict
the rest of the Constitution
to Madison's point,
but it makes it very clear
that you have the right to free speech.
Jeff, I mean, time goes by super fast
whenever we have these
interesting conversations,
I'll just send, you know, a few people
just asking a few questions, you know,
I've known you for several years and
I always like geeking out with you about
anything but especially
history and the Constitution,
but Niabe Solutia from YouTube says,
Jeff, what is an inspiration for
your academic aspect of life?
Maybe I'll interpret it that, like,
why did you get into this?
Why, you know, how did you get into
being the head of the
National Constitution Center?
What has driven kind of your
clear passion for the subject?
- Well, I've just always loved
reading and history and words.
And I was an English major in college
and I had some sense then
that my mission in life
was to bring together
English and government.
I didn't even know what that meant,
but I just felt impressed to
try to pursue that passion.
And I found that
in the study of the
Constitution and law school,
I went to law school
and I just was kindled with excitement
about the significance
of studying the text
and trying to understand
the arguments on both sides
and looking at the
philosophical foundations
and just growing and learning
and serving this much broader
goal friends, which is that
this document unites all of us.
So my path was that I began
after law school as a journalist,
I was writing about the Supreme
Court full time for a while.
And I loved doing that.
Then I started teaching Constitutional law
at GW Law School, where I still teach.
And then out of the blue,
as many of the greatest
opportunities in life do
the chance to work at
this amazing institution,
The National Constitution
Center presented itself.
And I am lucky enough to
work there since 2013.
And I just feel lucky every
single day I go to work
and my amazing colleagues and I
just have the opportunity
to teach and learn
and grow along with all of you.
And it's such a privilege in
these times to have this task,
this mission of convening
people of different perspectives
to learn about the Constitution.
Constitution day is a great way to do it.
It's wonderful to do what
you saw cause you're just
doing so much to inspire
people around the world
to learn about the Constitution.
And I wanna thank not only
all of our incredible friends
who are here in the U.S
but also those of you were
tuning in around the world to be inspired
by this great document of human freedom,
which has meant so much to unite
we the people, across
America and around the globe.
- Now, that's so inspiring.
Actually one last question.
I know we're a little bit
over time, but I can't,
I really wanna ask you
just given, you know,
all you hear about in
the media and the news
is on both sides you
know, it's very polarized.
You know, one party will view
the other party is, you know,
detached and crazy and then
likewise, it's symmetric.
Some people will even
vote that we, you know,
Constitutional crises.
This is not right,
where do you think we are on that journey?
Do you think that,
you know what all the
tension we see in politics
are just part of our, you
know, growth as a nation
and we're gonna get to a better place,
or do you have worries?
- Well, there's no doubt that it's
a very serious time for America.
Those statistics which are by the strands
that were more polarized
than in any time since the
civil war are very concerning.
In 1960, there was a 50% overlap
between the most conservative democrat
and most liberal Republican in Congress.
Today, there is no overlap and we all know
how social media has
amplified the partisanship
and the anger of our political discourse
in a way that seems to
empower the very factions
which Madison defined as
any group either a majority
or a minority animated by
passion rather than reason
devoted to self-interest
rather than the common good.
It seems like we're seeing
a lot of that rule by
passionate faction by
tweet and share rather than
by the reason deliberation
that the framers before.
On the other hand, I have
to say that, you know,
having some amazing job that I do,
I have the opportunity every day to see
how when you just take
the time to sit down
and have a thoughtful conversation
with people of different perspectives.
And I encourage people to do exactly
what I'm encouraging all of you to do now,
which is to set aside your
political disagreements,
cause we're not gonna persuade
each other about politics,
but to have enough
humility to learn deeply
about something you don't already
know the answer to namely,
what does the text say?
What were the original founding stories
that gave rise to it?
What is the Supreme Court said?
What are the philosophical arguments
that undergird these principles
and how should they apply in
light of changing technologies?
These are such hard and rich questions
that you end up after
it's spending some time
thinking about it.
I always end up in a surprising place
having learned something
that I didn't know before.
So I am very encouraged
that as long as we continue
to create the spaces,
the platforms like you're creating Sal,
like we're trying to create
The Constitution Center
where people can just take the time
to have this civil dialogues.
I am optimistic that the U.S Constitution
will continue to provide a
framework for civil dialogue
and that neither we the
people will continue
to rule ourselves by reason.
- Now well, that too is very inspiring.
And I got to say, cause I've
had the luxury of, you know,
we've done this in a
few Khan Academy videos
and National Constitution Center videos,
where we went into some of
the Supreme Court cases.
And, you know, a lot of
these cases I entered in
like surely they would vote this way.
Any reasonable person would,
but when you actually go into the details,
the intricacies of the case, you're like,
Oh, I guess they do have a good point.
And oftentimes you switch your position
when you really learn what's going on.
So yeah, I love that call to just
double, triple click on things.
Don't just take it, you know,
just don't look at things
and get outraged as quickly as possible.
You know, try to exercise some humility
to understand the other side.
So Jeff, thank you so much
happy Constitution Day.
And I think this was a real
treat on Constitution Day.
- Happy Constitution Day to everyone.
So excited to learn with you
and check out the
Interactive Constitution,
pick an Amendment or a pause
that you didn't know about
digging deep and enjoy the learning.
It's just such a joy to be able
to learn and grow together.
Happy Constitution Day.
- Right, thanks.
Thanks Jeff.
Well, thanks everyone for joining,
as always really fun conversation,
I highly recommend going to
The National Constitution
Center's website,
look at The Interactive Constitution,
attend those classes.
You might see me as one of your classmates
in some of those classes cause I think
not only will it help
you appreciate history
and how law and nations are constituted,
but it'll actually build your
critical thinking skills.
And I actually think the more people
that dig into these issues
at a higher level of depth,
I actually think that can
help the polarization problem.
Cause you could still
disagree with the other side,
but you can start to understand
some of the reasoning
for why a reasonable person
might come to a conclusion
that you don't.
So with that, thank you
so much for joining.
Let's see, I think the next show
is going to be on Tuesday of next week.
So have a good weekend.
See you all.
(notification sound)